[Music]
ralph waldo emerson once
quoted that
nothing great can ever be achieved
without enthusiasm
i have a lot of enthusiasm
[Music]
this is northlands in flemington new
jersey
northlands is the world's largest model
railroad
well i guess you know everybody has a
passion for something my thing was
trains had trains around the christmas
tree as a kid wherever i lived i'm
planning track plans and then over 18
years i added five basements onto the
house and from that i got fairly good at
making mountains and bridges and design
work and we decided to give it to the
world so we tore it all down bought this
land built northlands
any given day we run between 85 and 90
trains
some of the details in northlands inside
about forty thousand feet of track about
four thousand buildings
over four hundred bridges many of the
mountains in here are three and a half
stories high
most things in here are scratch built
underneath the entire superstructure
there's enough lumber to build about 42
large houses
takes a few hours to go through for the
average person
to see everything
we want millions into debt
to build this place everywhere i thought
we were nuts the only one that believed
that what i wanted to do was my wife and
she was totally with me on this big time
it's an artistic endeavor it's a gift to
the world of what i can do
and it makes a lot of people happy
[Music]
welcome to the 1880s
this train has been running through
these passes for over a century
there's no cell service up here no gas
stations and a whole lot of mountains
it's also the highest the longest and
one of the last authentic steam
railroads left in the country
there's probably no better ride with the
steam engine than this ride right here
that's jeff stebbins
jeff is an engineer for this train
officially known as the cumbers and
toltec railway
he's been working on this railroad for
the last 19 years on this 64 miles of
railroad i have about 50 000 miles
that would translate out to around the
earth about two times
today's trains are powered by diesel and
electricity but this one keeps it old
school by running on coal
we shovel about three and a half to four
and a half tons of coal a day
it's dirty work and back in the 1930s
trains began changing to diesel because
it was cheaper and more efficient
the coal-powered engines were phased out
this one survived thanks to the people
who cared about it and saw its beauty
this 64 miles of railroading through
southern colorado northern new mexico it
doesn't get much more beautiful than
this
the other thing about coal is that it
produces all that iconic smoke coming
off the train
the train takes visitors along its route
in the summer and fall
people come for the history more than
for the thrill of it
the train's top speed is only 20 miles
an hour
i love working on the railroad and i
look forward to
each morning that i come here
there's really
no place i'd rather be than the filthy
dirty locomotive
[Music]
the most recognizable thing in the sky
is obviously the silhouette of the
spitfire she's just a beautiful lady
i'm sure a lot of men would actually
like to marry her
i'm sure their wives wouldn't agree
there's 396 parts in a spitfire sea
how do i know that i built it
this is martin phillips my name is
martin phillips and i'm sitting next to
my spitfire rr232 which i'm the proud
owner of
martin is obsessed with
spitfires the big bombers join in
pounding the shoreline
in the darkest days of world war ii
spitfires filled the sky above england
they are an icon like freedom on wings
british kids make models of them
but martin took his spitfire devotion to
a whole other level
for his 40th birthday
martin's friends gave him a single
spitfire rivet
when i was presented with this rivet the
challenge was to go and build myself a
spitfire so on the spur at the moment
not thinking i said right i'll go out on
the monday morning and i will build a
spitfire i never thought that over a
period of 14 years that i'd probably
wear three cars out with mileage along
the journey to provide all the parts
that you now see today
so fuel tanks they came from norway and
sweden some of the other parts came from
russia
some of the parts came from israel some
of the other parts came from holland
came from france
one of the wings was offered to us
through a lost property department
and another wing came through a little
guy coming into work said i've got a
spitfire wing in my garden
the manners that go into a project like
this don't underestimate it they are
terrific and i know the blood sweat and
tears that went into that
after 14 years i know the question
you're going to ask me
do you fly it
sadly not
i am learning to fly and i hope one day
to fly it but greater guys than me fly
it my name's matt jones i'm a spitfire
pilot
the modern airliners fly 85 percent the
speed of sound they got spitfires flying
at 96 97
speed of sound
you don't get in a spitfire you strap it
on and it becomes a part of you
because the airplane means so much to so
many people there are a lot of people
who have
gone down martin's path and started
thinking they want to build a spitfire
but i've never met anyone else who's
completed it he dedicated his life to
finding the parts he needed to get this
airplane flying again
i went through these 14 years had
heartache and bits didn't fit
just putting it together and finishing
it in the providence and the journey the
journey i went on you know tears
even today i cry when it runs
it's just been amazing absolutely
amazing
[Music]
at aviation high school we take all your
regular academic classes english social
studies physical education but then also
we have ground operations carburetors
magnetos jet engines
this airplane behind me is my classroom
every day
i'm aaron schenczyk and i'm a student at
aviation high school and i currently go
to class at jfk airport
aviation high school is a public new
york city high school
students at aviation high school spend
four to five years working on
repairing airplanes and in the process
they get their licensing to work in the
industry from the federal aviation
administration
we have a hangar on site in our main
building where we have 17 aircraft
we've been teaching students for 81
years to work in the aviation industry
we're very proud to be the school that
certifies some of the most mechanics in
the country
the responsibility of an aircraft
mechanic is huge i have to ensure that
every single bolt every single screw
every single piece of wire is safely
secured on that aircraft prevent
anything from happening while it's in
the air
when we sign off any part it's basically
our signature that's allowing the
airplane to get into the sky and our
signature is worth gold we are letting
over 100 people on the ground get into
the sky and get to the destination
i like working with my hands i like
getting out in the world i love seeing
the work that i put in flying there
[Music]
okay just watch
three
two
one
this is thailand's mekong market
about an hour south of bangkok
every day beginning at 6 20 in the
morning a train runs through makelong
railway market one of the largest
produce and seafood markets in thailand
through the stalls selling fruit ice
cream fish
through everything
and if you're wondering which came first
the market of the train
the answer is the market
[Music]
the makelong railway built a commuter
train to bangkok back in 1905.
the track they laid ran right through
the middle of this market which had been
around for decades
rather than moving the vendors stayed
put adjusting their business to the
train times
eight times a day
seven days a week
[Music]
here
this system has been perfected over the
years with produce just inches from the
train's wheels tourists and vendors wait
as the train passes through
then everything goes back to normal or
at least as normal as an active train
line market can be
[Music]
you